[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Well, hi, everybody. Welcome
to the Data Science Hangout.
So nice to see everybody
here this Thursday.
Feels like this
week's flying by.
If we haven't gotten a
chance to meet before, I'm Rachael.
I am clearly the host of
our Data Science Hangout.
But I also lead customer
marketing at Posit.
The hangout is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing,
and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
So we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you end up watching this
on YouTube at a later date and
you want to join us live,
there'll be a link
in the details below,
where you can add it
to your calendar too.
But at the Data
Science Hangout,
we are all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everyone. We love
hearing from everybody,
no matter your years
of experience, your titles,
industry, or even the
languages that you work in.
So it is totally OK to
just listen in here if you want.
Maybe you're on your lunch
break or taking your dog for a
walk or something.
But there's also three ways you
can jump in and ask questions
or provide your own
perspective too.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom,
and I'll keep an eye
out for raised hands.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And if it's something you want
me to read out loud instead,
maybe if you're in a
coffee shop or something,
just put a little star next
to it in the Zoom chat.
And then lastly, we
have a Slido link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously too.
And I think Curtis will share that
in the chat here if he hasn't already.
But something I forget to
say sometimes. But if you are
on a team that's hiring,
feel free to share
open positions or
roles in the chat too.
I love to see all the
conversation that happens in
the chat during the hangouts,
even if I can't read it
while it's happening.
But with that,
I am so excited to introduce
my co-host for today,
Ben Arancibia, director
of data science at GSK.
And Ben recently spoke at Posit
Conference on the Need for
Speed and Accelerating R and
Other Open Source Tools for
Delivering Clinical
Trial Submissions.
So I'm excited we may get
to cover a few of the unanswered
questions from Slido
during this hangout too.
Ben,
I'll turn it over to you
to introduce yourself and share a
little bit about your role and maybe
something you like to do outside of work,
probably also confirming
pronunciation of your last
name. I'm sorry. I didn't do
that with you ahead of time.
- No. It was a
good pronunciation.
It's exactly how it's spelled.
So my name is Ben Arancibia.
I'm a director of
data science at GSK.
I sit within our
biostatistics organization,
specifically within
a group called SDSIH,
Statistical Data Sciences and
Innovation Hub. My role is
really focused on what I
like to call our enablement.
So I spend a lot of time
working with different business
groups to understand how they can
use R for the creation of outputs
to regulatory agencies or
talk to them,
understand what are their
needs in terms of tools,
and then help to build
tools for those specific business groups.
And then just try to
understand what are problems that people
encounter. So I
spend a lot of time
actively listening and bringing that
feedback to two different groups
to help solve those problems.
In terms of what I like
to do outside of work,
I'm a big runner, specifically
trail running. I do trail like
ultramarathons through
mountains, things like that.
So that's what I really
like doing outside of work.
I have two young
kids. So pretty much,
I'm either at home with
them or outside running
on some of the trails
around my house. So yeah.
That's a little bit about me.
- That's awesome. Well,
thanks for joining us, Ben.
And ultramarathon,
how many miles is that.
- So I haven't--
the race I just signed up
for is in March of next year.
It is 55km,
so 30, 33, 34 miles in the mountains
near Asheville, North Carolina.
So yeah, it's called the
Mount Mitchell Heartbreaker,
so I hope it doesn't break my
heart but we'll see how it goes.
- Impressive. You'll have to let
us know how it goes. Well, Ben,
something I thought might be
interesting to kick off the
conversation with as we're
getting questions from
everybody here is,
I know that you were a
consultant in a previous role
and might be good to hear
a little bit about your journey.
But also love to hear what
was it like transitioning from data
science as a consultant to data
science in the pharma industry too.
- Yeah.
So how I became a data
scientist, it's like, it's pretty funny.
I went to--
at university, I studied
like quantitative economics and geospatial
information systems and became a
GIS developer right out of
college working for the United
States Postal Service on a
federal contract. And I worked
on like route optimization. And
I was like, this is pretty
cool. I really like doing this.
And then the term like
big data came around,
and people became
data scientists.
And I thought to myself,
oh, wow. That's pretty cool.
Maybe I should just do that
instead of like being a GIS developer
and really get into data.
So that's what I ended up
doing is deciding, all right,
I'm going to focus more on--
more on data. I can always
go back to GIS later.
But really focus on trying to
understand how do I deal with
really large data sets
to solve different problems.
So I ended up
becoming a consultant.
I worked in
commercial consulting,
specifically for cybersecurity
clients, building
out different tools,
platforms, implementing
machine learning methodologies,
things like that.
And it was a really great way
to get exposure to lots of
different problems, as well as
being able to
build up my skills
for things like I might
not have learned at school.
And eventually,
what did I end up doing is
transitioning into the pharma
industry through to a great
leadership program that GSK
has called the Esprit Program,
which basically looks to
bring outside talent who has a
specific knowledge base and bring
it into GSK that they
want to expand upon. So
my cohort of Esprit candidates
were all data scientists.
And GSK biostats wanted to
bring data science expertise in-house,
and they do it
through this three-year leadership program.
So what we do basically
is we do rotational programs through
different groups within
the biostats organization,
bring our data science
expertise, and then they teach
us the pharmaceutical
industry business essentially during
those three years. And then at
the end of the three years,
you find a
final position within biostats.
But it's a great way
to think about, oh,
this person has some
interesting talent that we want
but they don't have the
business knowledge. How do we marry
the
lack of business knowledge with the
talent that we want to build?
And I think that's one thing
that I really love about GSK.
And sorry to be like a
GSK promoter right now but being
able to have that kind of space
to be able to learn and develop
is really crucial to being
able to create those good outcomes
for the business.
- Yeah. I'll echo
what Ben said.
It sounds like a great program
that a lot of other companies
may benefit from too.
And also realizing there's a
ton of love for geospatial in
the chat here too.
- Yeah.
That's cool to see about
all the people that love--
that love GIS.
- I'd love to hear a
little bit more about
what it's like going through
those rotations too and
teaching people data science.
Imagine you're doing
a lot of training.
And what it's like them
teaching you the pharma side of
things as well. Could
you give us an example?
- Yeah.
So one
of the things that came up
a lot of different times was really,
so if you think about pharma,
we're a highly
regulated industry.
And I think one of
the things that--
one of the conversations I
often had with people was,
well,
we can't do this because
we're a highly regulated industry.
And to go back to your
previous question about what I learned
from consulting,
because of the nature
of my work previously,
I worked in highly regulated
industries but we were able to
use open source tools.
So I think one of the
things that was really interesting going through
the rotational program and
talking to different business
groups and things like that was
being able to have that outside
pharma industry perspective
to say like, look,
you're highly regulated but
so is a lot of automobile
companies or oil and gas or XYZ
other companies as well.
And they're able to
use open source tools.
I think you might have to
think about it differently for your specific
industry.
But if you look at
like pure accounts of regulations,
I think automotive and oil
and gas and financial services all
have more laws and regulations
compared to pharma. So I think
one of the things that was
interesting was going through those rotations
and consistently having that
conversation that you
don't
just default because
you're highly regulated,
you can't use these tools,
it's figuring out how do
you use them safely within
the organization to make
sure you're satisfying those requirements.
- I got excited
by you describing that program.
And I jumped way ahead to
what you learned as a consultant.
But are there other things you
wanted to expand on about that?
- What else I learned
about consultant?
How to tell a good story.
I think that's one thing
that constantly when I'm working
with data scientists who
might be newer is like, how
do you tell your story about
what you learned during your
analysis or the outcomes or the
outputs from something? I'm sure
it's a trope by now,
but like communication and being
able to tell a really
nice story about what
it is that you did?
What is it that would
improve, a decision maker's
life is crucial.
And I think
one of the things that
data scientists or any analytics
professional has to balance
is not only can you do the
technical work, but can
you do the communication?
And can you tell
that nice story arc?
-
What's one of those
communication or storytelling
tips you'd share with us?
- Less is more.
I think, one of the--
I think if you can have
to go back to Posit Conf,
for everyone's
awareness, if you do a
talk at Posit Conf, you'll
go through like speaker training.
And one of the first trainings
or maybe the second one or
maybe it is just the first two,
you focus on figuring out
what is your governing idea. Like,
what is the one idea that
you want everyone to walk out from
after seeing your talk?
And I think that should be
applied to how you communicate
with stakeholders.
Less is more.
Figure out what it is that
you want someone to walk away with
based out of your
meeting. Because
if you're trying to show
like a presentation,
that presentation is not the
only thing that stakeholder is
going to do in that day.
They're going to be receiving
hundreds of emails per day.
They're going to have to
be making decisions, things like
that. So the question is like,
how do you make sure that they
get that one piece of
crucial information you want them to
have and really focus on that?
So less is more. What is
your one governing idea?
And then everything else
is just like extra gravy,
if you can get it.
But figure out what is that
one thing in order to make sure
that people walk away with it.
- Absolutely.
I know a lot of people
have joined since the first
beginning when I say how
people can jump into.
So I'd like to just
sometimes recommend or remind people,
if you have questions or things
you want to add to specific
topics, feel free to jump in
by raising your hand here on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And if it's something you want
me to read out loud instead,
you can just put a
little star next to it.
And then Curtis or Tyler will
reshare the Slido link in a
second too, if you wanted
to ask anything anonymously as well.
I realize sometimes I say that
too early when not everybody has joined.
But Yanan, I see you asked
a question here in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
YANAN REN: Hi. Hi,
Rachel. Hi, Ben.
- Hey, nice to see you.
YANAN REN: Yeah.
I have a question regarding
the R validation for the regulatory
submission to FDA.
In Medtronic, we usually
need to do our validation
after we have an updated
version of R. I don't know if
GSK has this requirement to
do our validation for the
submission work.
- Yeah. So GSK, we
do our validation.
A lot of how we do our
validation can actually be
found on the R validation hub,
which I think is part of the--
is either a positive
working group or
is loosely related.
So how we do it is really
taken from there. In terms of how
we do it, that R validation hub.
I can try to find
the link of the--
- I'll share it
for you right now.
- OK. Perfect.
- Yep.
- So that's--
- Going to beat me
to it. Thanks, Tyler.
- So yeah. So we generally
do that. We were a--
we being, GSK, were a strong
participant in figuring
out how to do it,
and then we worked with
basically our QA department to
make sure that we're checking all
the boxes that we need to
hit in order to say that,
yes, we believe that this is validated.
For those who are not
in the pharma industry,
maybe I'll explain
what validation means,
because it's like it's
an interesting problem.
So within
a biostats organization,
you basically have
two things that you need
to accomplish to move assets or
drugs through the pipeline.
Basically, one,
can you tell what--
can you trust the efficacy
of a drug? And you
trust the safety of
a drug or an asset?
And how you do that is you
write statistical code in order
to be able to prove that, yes,
we trust these statistical
tests that we've written.
In order to do that, you
need to do something that's called validation
for your software, which
is essentially to say,
we have tested this software,
and we believe that all the
outputs from this software is correct.
How you do validation is
defined by the organization.
But it's really important for you
to be able to trust your
software.
So there's a lot of testing
that goes into place in order
to get that level of confidence
within an organization that
says, yes, the software
can be trusted.
And there's different nuances for
how you do the testing.
So for example, if
you're using ggplot
for creating outputs of
graphics, things like that,
you can generally test
it through like code coverage,
as well as and basically doing
a couple like simple simulations.
And saying like, OK,
does it actually create the
output that we would expect,
that we would expect if
you were to put it, basically
create that output.
So there's that but then
there's also output.
There's validation from a
statistical correctness point
of view. So for example,
if we're writing a
piece of package to do
linear regression or doing a linear
regression or using a package
for linear regression,
how do you test
for that statistical correctness?
And that's a little bit more
of a thornier problem to figure
out, but it tends to
require a lot of different simulations,
things like that, in order
to be able to say yes.
From a statistical
correctness point of view,
we trust this
piece of software.
- Thank you.
YANAN REN: Thank you.
- Appreciate the
explanation there too. I see
Travis has a follow up question
around validation.
- Yeah. Thanks. Hopefully,
it's not too windy out here. I
had to take your walking the
dog thing literally.
My puppy needed to
go out. So anyway--
- That's OK. I was
also going to say,
does anybody remember when we were
talking about all getting hex tattoos
at a previous Data
Science Hangout?
Travis actually did that
in the conference. Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
- Yeah. It was fun. Hey,
Ben. So when you validate, I mean,
where are you all
hosting your R?
Is it like Workbench? Do
you run it in the Cloud?
Are these Docker
containers, local machines?
Like what do you do for that?
- Yeah. So what we
do is we have it--
we host it on Workbench.
And what we do basically is
we create what's known as a frozen
R environment,
which is basically an
environment that has a set
number of packages that we have
gone through the validation
process with and said, yes,
we trust these packages.
So then what we do is
then we create basically a frozen R--
I don't know.
It's not it's not truly
a container but basically an
execution script where we can
then basically just take and
install that in
any system that we choose.
So the goal is to
make it system agnostic. So for
example, if we want
to install it in
a Posit Workbench,
on our own internal--
our own internal RStudio, Cloud
environment, we can do that.
If we want to do it on--
I don't know. Pick your
data science workbench,
domino.
I don't know. Whatever.
Different things like that,
you're able to do it.
But trying to making it--
trying to make it
system agnostic.
- That's cool.
Thanks. Yeah. I mean,
there's like two levels
to the validation.
It always seems like validating
the packages inside of R and
then validating the
installation of R itself.
And that latter one is the
one that we've had the most
challenges with on R. How do
you prove that R is actually R,
this sort of the
spirit of what
FDA wants to see.
And we find that
surprisingly difficult.
- I think they're coming
around to it though.
If you see some of the
talks that they've given in terms of
the R adoption series and
things like that. I think there--
and also, I mean frankly,
if you just look at statistical
masters programs and things
like that, like R is now
the tool to use. So I think
from a, call it a
culture point of view,
I think that's changing pretty
rapidly, just because of
how the workforce is changing.
- Hey, Tim. I see
your hand raised.
- Yeah.
Just talking about the whole
package and R validation front,
that's one area where
the combination of Workbench
and Connect I've found really
helps. Because when I'm
publishing to Connect using
Packrat, it's
making sure that
everything is valid,
that it's a snapshot of
the packages that were used to
publish it. And even though I
upgrade R on the host machine
and deploy other packages
or other apps with different
levels of software,
that one that I encapsulated
when I published it before
stays that way, unless I make a
specific decision to update
components. Just a plug for
integration of
Workbench with Connect.
- Absolutely. Thanks, Tim.
I see Priyanka had a
follow-up question on this topic too.
Do you want to jump
in here, Priyanka?
Oh, I can ask it if you have
a spotty connection. But
the question was
like, is that--
well is that using RM and
then I see Travis asks Packrat
versus RM. I don't
know the distinctions of that.
Could anyone speak to that.
- Yeah, Tim, you mentioned
you were using Packrat.
And that--
we use R. I think
it's the same. But
I don't know the
difference.
- Yeah. I think both are
used when it gets published.
Packrat manages the package
versions and does the uploading
so basically, it's like a
Docker Lite for your packages
that makes sure that they're
all of the revs are
there. And it keeps a--
it keeps a library in the
background and makes sure that
everything's synced up.
And
I would imagine R--
RNV is used as well.
But I don't know the
technical details of that.
One nice thing about publishing to
Connect is I don't have to.
It just does it
on the background.
But if I was writing
it myself, yeah,
I'm sure you'd have to use
a combination of both if you
weren't packaging--
if you weren't publishing
direct to Connect.
-
I can share a link in the
chat in just a minute about this too.
But Lisa, I see you had
a question a bit earlier
about being outside of pharma
and how things might relate.
Do you want to ask that?
- Yeah. I mean, I think
I'm most curious about just
learning the pharma lingo,
which has like every industry,
a lot of abbreviations to it.
And then just really also
trying
to understand that whole
process and think about how
those same ideas might,
even though maybe I'm in an
industry that's less regulated,
how some of those ideas might
want to steal some of those,
because it might just be
good practice in general.
So just where to
good places to start learning
and I already saw our
Pharma Conference
posted out there.
So any other ideas
would be great.
- I think at the core of
the pharma world is basically,
can you reproduce
your outputs? And can you
trust and verify those outputs?
So you could learn--
you could learn
the pharma lingo
if you want it.
But I think the core
thing is like, do you-- can
you figure out how
to create reproducible data
pipelines essentially?
And I think if you are
able to do that through
different methods
as well as using
potentially RMs in terms of
how to manage your environment,
things like that.
I think you actually will--
you actually know more.
Like that's essentially
the core of what is pharma
principles essentially
is how do you reproduce--
how do you make sure
that it's reproducible?
And how do you make sure
that you can trust and verify your
outputs? And I think
that's the core.
- Awesome. So I
have to learn RM.
[LAUGHS]
-
There are definitely a lot of
great resources on RM if maybe
someone in the background
wouldn't mind sharing some of
their favorites in the
chat too, that'd be great.
But I did want to also--
I put this in the
chat, but also
because it just came
out, just came up,
give a shout out to some of
the free workshops that are
happening this week for the
RM Pharma Conference which is open
to everybody, regardless of if you
are working specifically in that field.
But there's a ton
of great workshops
all this week and then
the conference is next week.
And so I shared that in
the chat just a second ago.
Awesome. There was another
other question a bit earlier
and I'm not finding it
specific exactly, but
the question was, Ben,
can you give us a
little bit more background around your
role too and what
your team looks like?
- Yeah. Sure. So my role is
really, I like to split it up
into, call it
four pillars of responsibility.
I have a team that
focuses on building end-to-end applications
for
trying to gather insights about
data related to either clinical
trials or some of our
business partners outside of biostatistics.
One I can give a
shout out to is called
the BPH tool,
which is an externally facing tool
on how to treat a certain--
a certain urological--
it's not disease
but called symptoms.
So I'll put that in the chat.
But we built that using Shiny.
It's linked to
scientific manuscripts.
And so one of the things
that we try to do now is when
we submit a manuscript,
try to either submit an
interactive tool or enhanced
graphics with the manuscript
in order to make it easier for
people to understand
the data. So that's one team.
I have a team that focuses
on building like open source packages.
One of the big things we're
looking at now is like Bayesian statistics.
Then I have a third team
that's focused on doing
basically R training as well
as R enablement. So we have a
program called Accelerate R which
is a group of agile--
it's an agile pod of data
scientists and R programmers
that go basically
study-to-study, sit with them
for 9 to 10 weeks, train
them on the use of R
and then basically leave
after those 10 weeks,
but really set up those
studies to be able to use R
effectively.
And then I have a fourth like
pillar of responsibility,
which is focused on being
engaged in like data science
working groups and different things
like that in order to be
able to talk about R, as
well as be able to have
industry standard for how
to use R for different ways
for clinical trials.
And we talk about things
that might sound silly,
like how do you round in
R versus Sas and Python. But
being able to talk very
confidently about those
differences and why you might
get differences in results is a
pretty crucial aspect for our industry.
- I know you just mentioned the training piece.
But I realize that's like
a huge undertaking with so many
different trainees. And I was
wondering how do you scale
that training out? I
think when we talked,
you said that
there's 800 trainees?
- Yeah. So within biostats,
GSK biostats, we're about 900 people.
So what we started to
do initially was having just open
in-person, as well as
virtual trainings with R.
So like I think we got
to the point where 80%
of biostats took an
introduction to Tidyverse R
training, which is like 80%
of 900 is like right
around 707, 720, something like that.
And what we were finding
was people just weren't up taking
the training and using
it on clinical trials.
And the big reason we
found out was because
you would take the training
and then you wouldn't actually use--
wouldn't
use R until like 12
or 18 months later.
So what we ended up doing
was deciding like, all right,
let's just put all R
training as on demand.
Like I'm never going to write
a better like intro to Tidyverse
training than either Hadley's written
or someone else has written online.
Let's just make it all on
demand when you want to do it
and focus purely on
support and mentoring.
So what we do is we have
this small group of people,
and they go, basically
study-to-study,
whoever wants to use R
at that period of time,
and we work with them.
And the goal is basically train
that study team up and create
them into champions and then
also give them the confidence
to be able to go
to other studies and help provide
guidance as well.
So we do it
through that support and mentoring,
but we also have
big community engagement through different
like open forums where
people can ask questions,
things like that.
So it's really
focused on spending
less time on creating
materials for training and documentation
and more time on
figuring out, all right,
how do we actually do support
and mentoring as well as get
feedback to build tools that
actually will help our users
for actually using R
on clinical trials?
- And Ben, I see you have
a question in the chat,
do you want to in here?
- Yeah.
I was curious, Ben, if you have
other cross disciplines across GSK
as it's so large. I mean,
obviously you have
a large enough
group you're working with
to try and ramp them up.
But it seems like there
could be other opportunities that would
enhance the efficiency of the tools
and so on and so forth.
- Yeah. There's lots of
different data science groups.
Like I feel like sometimes,
you just stumble upon them, because
I think GSK, I
think we're like
100,000 people or something like
that, maybe a little bit less.
And so you're just like,
you're just like, you
just stumble upon them.
For biostats, we're
pretty large luckily.
So we work a lot with
our business partners.
And the reason why we work
with them is like because biostats
really focuses on moving
assets through the pipeline,
we have direct impacts
on like HR or finance,
so like we have
those connections that we do.
But like we have a whole like
AI group that's focused
on computational biology and
computational chemistry and
different things like that.
So there's lots of different--
lots of different data
science groups within GSK.
Some of them work across
departments but a lot of them
tend to work like within
their own department,
because they're so
hyperfocused on specific problems
that they're trying to solve.
-
I was talking to someone at
the conference who works in pharma
and hearing about some of
the different finance use cases
within pharma, which I wouldn't
initially think about as well.
- Yeah.
-
It's cool to hear about
all the different data science teams
across companies.
This was actually a Slido
question from your conference
talk which I thought
because we didn't get to it,
we could cover it here.
But it was,
how do you think about
redefining the way that people
see themselves? Like helping
statisticians see themselves as
programmers and using
Git for example.
- Yeah.
So I actually don't believe
in having people redefine themselves.
I actually think about how
do you help someone
learn a tool or add a tool
to their toolkit in order to
enhance the way that
they're working.
Because at the end of the day,
you are not going to turn
like a statistician into
a programmer or a computer
scientist or things like that,
unless they really
want to become one.
So I think the goal is
like you don't actually try to redefine
them. I think you try to
help them add tools to their toolkit
in order to be able to--
in order to be able to use
it in order to enhance their work.
So like teaching is--
there's teaching like
a statistician Git.
Like you have to explain why
it's important for them to know,
the hit by the bus
rule, if anyone's familiar with that.
But yeah-- [INTERPOSING
VOICES]
- You use the, what if
you won the lottery--
- Or yeah. What if--
- You're hit by a bus.
- Yeah. That's a better way
to put it, I guess. But yeah,
so like I think it's for more
focus on how do you help people
add and not
necessarily redefine.
- Absolutely. And
is this the training initiative
something that's come from the
top at GSK? Or how was
it first rolled out?
- Yeah. So
I mean, it was more--
it wasn't necessarily--
it wasn't really rolled
out from the top.
It was more like
we got the blessing
from the leadership
team that says, hey,
we want to try something
pretty different.
Are you OK with this approach?
And got the thumbs up. And so
we got the thumbs up to say,
yeah,
go and try this new way
to train, focus less on the
classes, focus more on
support and mentoring.
And that's how we
were able to do it.
So it was--
luckily,
we were given the freedom and
the latitude to be able to try
something new and in the
spirit of agile fail fast,
if it didn't work. But it
has worked pretty well. So luckily,
it wasn't something that
had to be top-down driven.
And I think it's a model
that could be utilized pretty much
in any organization.
Because really,
all you need is people who
are passionate about R and willing
to spend some time to do
that support and training. So yeah.
- I see a pretty big
conversation happening in the chat around
rounding
and can somebody explain to me,
I've heard of this and how numbers
can be different in Sas versus R,
but I would love to understand a
little bit more of what that means.
I see a bunch of
links being shared.
- Yeah.
In general,
so someone correct me if I
messed this up. But in general,
computer science has adopted the
strategy that if you have
something that ends
in 0.5, like 2.5,
you around the
even numbers down.
So like 2.5 becomes 2 and
the odd ones round up. So 3.5
becomes 4.
And so what that
does is on average,
if you have a whole bunch
of numbers that end in 0.5,
then the rounding up and
down like on average,
doesn't really matter.
SaaS on the other hand,
is the only language that
will round everything in 0.5 up.
So if you had a whole bunch,
if you had a whole bunch
of numbers and you rounded them all,
you would actually get an
average that is higher than the
true average was.
Because everything got rounded up
instead of like every other
one getting rounded up. And
it's a very annoying nuance for
submissions to FDA or
sponsors or investigators when they're
used to seeing SaaS outputs
and everything that's
0.5 being rounded up,
they start to question that.
And indeed at the FDA, if
you submit something in R,
you might get a mismatch
in SaaS because of that rounding
problem. It's a weird one.
-
Do you have to write
like custom functions to do R
rounding like SaaS in order to
get around that or just explain
it away via differences?
- Yeah. Those do exist. I
and Stephanie in here shared
a really good resource that
looks like some packages
and other people have developed
around this idea.
But yeah, for sure.
I mean, you can.
There are custom functions
that we sometimes write if they
really just insist that
everything 0.5 rounds up, then
we go, yeah. OK.
And we just note it.
- Thank you for
that explanation.
Yeah, sometimes,
it's like if something's
been said like enough times,
it's like, do I pretend that
I know what that actually means?
Or do we just stop and ask?
Katherine, see you had a
question here in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
- Yeah.
You mentioned that you've
switched the way that you're
training from a previous method
and that it's been successful.
But how are you
measuring that success?
We're currently rolling out
like a data science mentorship
program and trying to figure
out how do we measure how
successful we've been at
mentoring this person when we
don't necessarily want to turn
them into a machine learning
engineer or a
programmer or something.
We just want them to be
better data scientists
and data professionals.
- Yeah. So for us
specifically, we're pretty--
we try to keep it very simple,
which is basically like
how many outputs are
we creating with R?
And is that number increasing?
And if the answer is yes,
then we're hitting our
metrics essentially.
Or is the number of clinical trials
that we want to use R in
some part of increasing?
Then the answer is yes.
We believe that we are hitting
our tracking or our metrics
in order to say yes,
our enablement is increasing.
If you're talking about
how do you make someone--
how do you make--
how do you track if someone
is improving their skills,
to me, that's more
like a development plan
point of view at an
individual level.
But I think it's really hard. I think
you can only do it in terms of--
if you really want to track,
I think it has to be like
at an aggregate output level
and not necessarily, did
this person like comprehend,
unless it's like
at a development
or a career or personal
development level, if that makes sense.
- Yeah, I think that
makes a lot of sense,
especially given that your
team's goal is R enablement.
That's something that's fairly
straightforward to track.
Are we seeing higher
use of R? Yeah.
We're doing the professional
development part,
was a lot harder. We
had a couple ideas. But really,
one of those things is,
are they using Git now?
And that's something that we're
tracking as part of that too.
- Yeah. That gets really hard,
having gone through like those
wars with like trying to teach
people how to use it,
like it's the steepest learning
curve that I think I've ever
encountered with teams. It just--
it's really, really tough.
And there's just so
many points of friction.
Just like when you get
your first merge conflict and you
just don't know what to do.
And it seems like the world
just like will not let you
merge your branches together.
Like it is a really,
really tough thing.
- You just unprotect your branches
and merge them anyway. It's fine.
- Yeah.
But then you got to explain
it to someone later on
reproducibility, right?
- I see
Rebecca had a question. There's
a star, so I'll read it.
But it expands on this.
But how are you like
demonstrating or showing that
evidence for it working?
Like are you--
I guess, to expand on this,
are you presenting this
to anybody as well?
- What specifically
in terms of what?
- I think about
to expand on how
you're measuring or tracking the
success against the
previous method.
- Yeah. I mean, I
don't think we--
I mean,
we're not trying to get to
a world where R replaces SaaS.
We want to live in a world
where you can select the tool
that you want to use to
create your outputs. So
if our goal is to
make R a primary
programming language
or a tool that can be
used, we should be--
and there's an interest, then we
should be able to see increase
of the use of R.
So like don't look at it as--
I look at it as like
you have options,
and we want to make
sure those options are being utilized.
And not like how do I get
R usage from 10% to 100%
within my organization.
- Thank you.
Kevin, I see you had
a question around the cultural barriers.
Want to jump in?
- Yeah. Sure. Yeah. I think
you spoke a little bit to this,
but I was just curious if
you could elaborate more on how you
dealt with cultural barriers to
adopting open source in pharma,
especially like, yeah,
it's a regulated industry.
And almost want
to frame it like,
was it more helpful to show
the efficacy of open source?
Or was it more important
to show the safety of it?
Like or this both important?
You know what I mean?
- Yeah. Yeah. So the big
thing that actually was the major--
major way that we broke a lot
of ground in terms of open
source was visualizations.
So because one of the big
things that R does so well is
ggplot and being able to
create awesome visualizations
with data. And that
was something that SaaS
really, really struggled with.
And so the wedge that we
actually figured out in order
to be able to start having
the open source conversation was like,
look at all these cool
like visualizations and look how
easy it is to make
these visualizations
compared to other
programming languages.
Why don't we like start looking at open
source as a way to be able to
basically use tools
successfully? And then
a lot of things happened.
But I think the big
another thing that really has broken
through cultural barriers
has been there's a really,
really strong industry,
call it collaboration,
called like the
Pharmaverse where different
companies, so like Roche, GSK,
Novartis, J&amp;J,
like all these different
companies are creating open
source packages for the
clinical trial development
pipeline. So like
if you can set,
if you as an industry can
agree upon like we all trust these
open source tools,
it really kind of helps
to break down those cultural
barriers about why should I
use this open source tool.
And it's really easy
to say like, well,
we want to use it because
Roche is using it or we've developed
it with Roche and with--
insert
other pharma company.
And you can say, we
helped create it,
we should trust it.
And so I think that has
been one of the things that has
helped with those
cultural barriers.
- Did you just get--
one follow up,
did you ever hit a wall where
there's some parts of the
organization or some people,
some managers who just
like can't get over
the validation or the concerns
about open source? Or did you
find you were able to pretty much
break through in most when you needed to?
- I think you can break
through. But at the end of the
day, like I try to
talk a little bit about earlier,
like if people
want to use their
proprietary tool, fine.
If it helps them do their work
like at the end of the day like
all I care about is like,
can you do your work?
And can you do your work in
a timely manner and not have
bottlenecks with platforms?
And if the answer is yes,
then who cares? If that's
your preferred tool,
that's where you like
to spend your time,
then I'm not going to
tell you differently.
- That makes
sense. Thanks, man.
- Thank you all for
the great questions. If
anybody feels like their
questions are getting missed,
I'm sorry. If we missed
them in the chat,
so feel free to repost below
in the Zoom chat as well.
But there was one
anonymous question
that was--
when
we say like what the FDA
wants to see, what does that
actually mean? Like do those
statements come directly from FDA
employees? Or where
do people hear that?
- In terms of--
I mean, you could talk a little
bit about the FDA in terms of--
I
think there's like
guidance on software.
Like if I was Phil Bowsher,
I would have the PDF up already
on what it is that you can use.
But I think there's a lot of--
when
you submit something to an
FDA or another regulatory agency,
it's like an open conversation.
And you have a conversation.
And so it's not just like--
it's not a piece of homework
where I have to submit this at
midnight and then
I get a grade.
There's like an ongoing
back and forth conversation that
occurs. And so--
being able to engage and
have those conversations is where
you learn exactly what it
that is needed from a regulator.
Now there's expected standards and
you know what standards it
is that you have to hit
in terms of having a successful
submission or
ad hoc analysis or whatever it
might to be able to answer a
scientific question.
But it's not--
like I said, it's not it's
an ongoing conversation.
It's not like a submit your homework
and you hope you get a good grade.
- Thank you, Ben.
Ahmed, I see you had a question
you just put into the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah, sure.
For the different Bayesian
statistics that could be used,
I gather it's going to be
different between discovery and
like drug discovery or clinical
trial data analysis versus
sales or things of that nature.
And I'm not sure if
Ben deals with both.
But I was curious if
some of the algorithms that
are proprietary could or have been
used in R or developed in R.
- I can't speak specific about
Bayesian lab.
I can tell you our approach
to Bayesian statistics is
open source. It's published
in different journal articles,
things like that. We
focus on Bayesian dynamic borrowing.
That's like our
focus in terms of how it
is that we use Bayesian stats.
But I can't--
I don't know enough about some
of the stuff that goes on in
Bayesian lab to be able
to answer that question.
- Travis, if you put a
question to the chat here, if
you want to jump in.
- I'm sorry I feel like
I'm talking too much. Hi, everyone again.
- Ben--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Don't worry,
I'll stop calling on somebody
if they talk too much.
[LAUGHS]
- OK. Good.
Ben,
I'm sure, like all of us in
the pharma adjacent space,
you probably watched
the Novo Nordisk talk,
the Journey to NR Submission.
Yeah, you're nodding. Yeah. Yeah.
It was awesome. We were
all waiting for that one.
And they're very open for--
everyone who didn't see it,
about challenges with
submitting things that the FDA
maybe hasn't seen before.
They're like they
submitted several times.
You have to do is like
nah, this doesn't work on my machine.
And then to Ben's point
about it being a conversation, they
had a conversation, and
they work through it.
So I was wondering
if you had any just
gut reactions about that
talk, like any further commentary,
you might color, you might want
to add to what they showed?
- Yeah.
There are two things that I
really took away from that talk.
One,
it was a really similar story.
We all are solving the same
problem albeit in our different
ways based off like our
organizational culture or just
organizational preferences.
The
big thing I took away
from it actually is
if we are going down the
open source route in terms of
R and different R
packages, things like that,
I think it's actually going
to potentially create a stronger
culture of open source tools.
Because
it seemed like the--
and by that, I mean,
I don't know if
specific companies will
be able to have internal
tools that only they can use
because of the issues that Novo had
with using their own internal
tools and trying to do a
submission because of how do I
get them to be able to install
this package, which might
not be available on CRAN,
how do I be able to do this?
So I think it actually--
one of the things that it's
made me think a lot about is
how much
internally do we actually
want to create because of the
hiccups that could cause in
the actual submission process?
And will that potentially
result in a stronger
open source ecosystem? Because of
just like, just the making
it easier in order for
regulators, whether it be FDA,
EMA, Japan, whatever it might to
be able to use these tools.
- That's such a great answer.
Yeah, I felt the same.
There was that one part
in their talk where they said,
well the solution was just
we needed to open source
everything, and then the FDA was
happy. And I was like, oh,
I didn't expect that.
But it's almost like--
it's a good advisory tip
for those of us developing internal
packages at our companies, like
that may not be a sustainable
journey in the future
when we go to submit.
- Yeah.
And I think the big thing that
I have been thinking a lot
about is the reason why
we've never encountered this,
we being the pharma industry has
never encountered this, is because say,
SaaS is your tool of
choice. Theoretically,
SaaS is the same from
one organization to
the other. And I keep harping
on this, so I'm sorry,
but like
reproducibility is key.
So if it exists in tool--
if your proprietary tool exists
in two organizations in the
same version XYZ,
then you have to make sure that
that's guaranteed if you're
using open source tools.
And from
a philosophical point of view,
that probably means we have to
open source more to make sure
that everyone has access,
and we don't have these very
secret internal tools that
cause issues with submissions.
- Thank you.
Ben, a question
I'd love to get to
ask people is about
career advice they've received over
the course of their career
or have given. Do you
have something that stands out?
- Oh, man.
I think the thing that always stuck
with me is it's OK to say no.
Like you should be ruthlessly
prioritizing your time and
trying to work on things
you're passionate about.
So it's OK to say no to
certain things if you
are the wrong fit.
It's also, if you think
about your brand management,
it's sometimes
nice to be wanted.
So saying no sometimes is good
for that brand management.
So I think being comfortable
with the word no and
is really important.
The other thing and I think
is really important or the other
piece of advice I
was given to me,
and I try to live by
this value is like be radically transparent.
So meaning,
no matter what, just be like,
just no such thing as holding
cards close to your chest
basically say like here's what
I got. What do you have?
And really focus on being able
to have those open and honest
conversations, which I think
leads to greater vulnerability,
which is like how you make
connections with people
and really are able to
be empathetic with people and
trying to understand
their problems.
So I think being able to say no
and also being able to
be radically transparent is really crucial
work advice that people,
that a lot of mentors
have given me in the past.
- Absolutely. Thank you
so much for sharing that.
OK. I don't want to have--
I don't want to take the
last few questions if there's
anything that I've missed here,
so please feel free to raise
your hand if I have missed one
of your questions in the chat.
But I'll jump ahead with--
OK. I'll keep an eye out,
but I'll jump ahead with
one I wanted to ask as well.
I know in your role,
you get to connect with so
many different teams through
training and education.
And I'm curious how that's
helped you in your role and how
you build these relationships
with people and maybe maintain
those relationships.
- Yeah.
I really like it because
I'm able to understand more about
like, what do people--
what are people facing?
And
one of the things that I've
learned is like every--
or one thing, one learning
I've had from it is like,
no one's trying
to do a bad job.
It's just there's so many
things that are going on in
life that you have to--
people require like certain
different levels of support.
They all want to try--
they all want to do the
new cool thing. It's just--
everyone's at different stages.
So I think being able to
connect with different teams,
understand how it is--
where they are in their point
of life or where they are in
their like development journey in order
to be able to do these things,
it's really important to
be empathetic and learn
and be able to take those
learnings and bring it to other teams.
And I think that's one thing
that I find really cool about
my job is like being
able to connect with these different
teams, bringing learnings
from different places
and bringing it to other
teams, make those connections.
As well as bring what are the
problems that people are facing to our
different tools teams or to my
tools team to be able to say
like, here are things
that I'm hearing.
What are your thoughts?
And I think like,
a great example of this was
another talk at
Posit Conf from GSK,
we created this open
source tool called Slushy,
which is built on top of RM
do environment management.
So
I don't know if we would have
ever gotten to that point
without being able to go out
to these different teams and like
actually listen to what
are their problems for
what they're encountering
if they want to use R
for that creation
of their outputs.
- Yeah.
Was trying to go find the
link to that talk but I forgot
they're not all public yet but they
will be in the next few months.
Ben, was there anything
that after your talk,
you thought about, oh,
I wish I also covered this
or maybe a question that was asked
of you that you had
wanted to expand on.
- I think the
biggest thing is--
if you really want to--
if you really want
to enable learning,
you actually need to put
the support behind it.
And I think the big thing that
I wish I was more focused on
in that talk was,
can do as much
training as you want.
But if you're not
actually using it
in the creation of an output,
that's where you actually
learn how to do things.
And there needs to be a
really robust support team behind to
help answer those questions.
And I wish I hit that
more is just really focused on that
support and mentoring.
It's really hard to scale,
I realize, because it's actual
hours and not a piece of
document that someone can go
read but that support and
mentorship is crucial for being
able to change and enable
an organization to use a tool.
-
And I'm sorry if I missed
this in the beginning when you were
describing the different roles in
the team, but is there this
idea of a help desk or
center of excellence or would people
go for additional support?
- Yeah. So that's what
that Accelerate R team is.
And we have a giant community
forum where people are able to
post questions as well.
I think we call it like
R for clinical forum and people will
just post questions or post
announcements about new
packages and things like that.
So we have not only
a the direct support,
but we also have the a robust
community that has a Teams
channel where there's an active
communication that occurs that
answer questions or celebrate
wins things like that.
- That's awesome. Thank you so
much Ben for joining us today
and sharing your
experience with us.
I wanted to--
there are so many helpful
links shared in the chat today.
I wanted to remind people if
you wanted to save the chat,
there's this little three
dots in the bottom of Zoom.
You can press those and press
save chat so you can have all
of those links as well.
But Ben, if people wanted to
connect with you after, is LinkedIn
the best place?
- Yeah. I will drop my
LinkedIn in the chat right now.
So if you have an interest
in connecting and sending me a
message if you have other
questions like, yeah,
don't hesitate to connect.
- Great. Thank you so much.
One thing before people go.
I saw Libby had posted
this week about something about
learning Tidymodels and I saw
there was so much interest from
the community.
And this month--
our
monthly end-to-end workflow demo
is going to feature Simon
Couch from the Tidyverse team who's
actually going to be going through
Tidymodels and using that with
Posit team. So I just wanted
to share the short link
to that if people wanted to
add it to their calendar.
You absolutely don't have
to register for anything.
It will just be
on the Posit YouTube as well.
But it seems like there's a
lot of interest in Tidymodels,
there, so wanted to share it.
But thank you all
so much for joining.
Have a great rest of
the day. Thanks, Ben.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
- Thanks so much, Ben.
Bye everybody.
- Bye, bye.